actualización de las noticias económicas
con Juan Pablo lucumi Juan Pablo saludo
nuevamente para usted acá estamos para
actualizar las noticias de economía
Vámonos con un bloque de latinoamericano
y la inflación sigue golpeando por
supuesto el bolsillo de los argentinos
con el encarecimiento de los productos
más consumidos allá no es sorpresa la
carne estamos hablando de la carne usted
de Argentina no pero tenemos que ir a
probar la deliciosa carne de ese lugar
pero de pronto en otro momento porque
por ahora los precios de la carne de res
subieron cerca de un 30% esto en las
últimas dos semanas generando gran
preocupación entre la población que pues
tiene la fama por su consumo de carne y
hacer grandes asados esto los fines de
semana el precio de la carne cerró en
2022 con un incremento anual del 42%
cuando la inflación alcanzó un
94,8 por ciento integral esto en
diciembre la mayor tasa desde 1991 el
aumento de precios de los cereales y las
sequías son solo algunos de los factores
que explican el encarecimiento de la
carne
vemos lo que dicen los argentinos
lo que es la carne tengamos en cuenta
que lo que es la carne el pollo del
cerdo venía frenado hace tres meses el
aumento es muy brusco Por lo cual la
gente al mostrador lo sintió un montón y
muchos han buscado opciones más baratas
o de menor calidad y llevo bajado no sé
pero un 70% consumo de carne acá todo el
mundo o sea el asado nos faltaba el fin
de semana y hoy en día tiene que buscar
alternativas puede que eventualmente en
países como argentina se note más pero
la verdad es que el encarecimiento es
algo que sufrimos todos y nos afecta el
bolsillo todos los días Juan Pablo vamos
a cambiar a Colombia a nuestro país
radicó el plan Nacional de desarrollo
del presidente llamado Colombia potencia
Mundial de la vida hablemos de eso Esto
fue el día de ayer el plan de Gustavo
Petro se basa en lo que él llama Paz
total justicia social y la justicia
ambiental el plan está calculado en
cerca de 240 mil millones de dólares y
los Pilares son el ordenamiento del
territorio alrededor del agua a la
seguridad huma el derecho humano también
la alimentación una economía productiva
para la vida y acción climática todo
esto bajo la convergencia regional el
presidente colombiano dijo que la actual
crisis económica del país responde a los
problemas internacionales de inflación y
de guerras y también dijo que la
economía colombiana se debilitó por
decisiones de otros gobiernos de
importar alimentos que se pueden
producir en el país esto como el maíz y
que su administración debe revertir
muchas decisiones del expresidente Iván
Duque la vicepresidenta Francia Márquez
tuiteó Este es un plan Nacional de
desarrollo realmente histórico con la
gente y por la gente capaz de entender
otras naciones del desarrollo Las
Naciones del buen Vivir del vivir
sabroso del vivir sin miedo y de la vida
digna para todos todas y todo es cierro
comillas pero ahora escuchemos las
declaraciones del presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro
es así como podemos reactivarnos
económicamente y de manera permanente es
que al combinar como en un sancocho ese
capital que se puede entregar esos
espacios y esos saberes es que sale una
sociedad rica del capital no sea para
diez personas sino para millones de
colombianos y colombianas
esa estrategia de reactivación la verán
en el proyecto de ley de adición
presupuestal
y la verán de manera muchísimo más
profunda en este plan Nacional de
desarrollo por ahora vamos a pasar a
Australia aumentó este país sus tasas de
interés para enfrentar la inflación el
tema de todos nuestros días seguimos
hablando de inflación El Banco Central
de Australia elevó Este martes su tasa
de interés de referencia por novena vez
consecutiva el aumento fue de 0.25
puntos básicos dejando los tipos en 3,35
por ciento la decisión del Banco Central
australiano fue en gran parte debido a
la inflación del último trimestre de
2022 que es como normalmente pues se
evalúa el tema de las tasas cuando
alcanzó el
7,8%, la más alta de 1990 desde 1990 y
muy lejos de su objetivo de llevarla
entre el 2% y el 3% con la esperanza de
evitar la recesión hoy en cada segmento
de directo América hemos dedicado una
parte para hablar de las consecuencias
en Turquía y en Siria después del
terremoto háblenos ustedes desde su
punto de vista Hablemos del tema
económico en palabras del presidente
Turco recepy perdogan su país se
enfrenta a la catástrofe más fuerte en
un siglo el lunes el rendimiento de la
deuda pública local a diez años alcanzó
su nivel más alto en casi dos meses con
un 10,2%, según las autoridades el
terremoto deja al menos 4 aeropuertos
turcos dañados y más de 6.000 edificios
cayeron esto en Turquía entre Los
afectados también están los tres coma
millones de refugiados sirios
registrados en Turquía el observatorio
sirio de Derechos Humanos reportó daños
totales o parciales en 58 aldeas pueblos
y ciudades esto al noreste de Siria y
muchos de los hospitales se quedaron sin
recursos para atender a los heridos
ankara detuvo el flujo de petróleo a la
terminal de exportaciones de Ceylan en
la costa mediterránea como medida de
precaución aunque no se detectaron fugas
en los oleoductos que alimentan la
instalación el seiyan es un centro vital
para las ventas de petróleo desde el
norte de Irak y azerbaiyán el puerto
exportó más de un millón de barriles
diarios En enero el 1% el suministro
mundial de petróleo el cierre contribuyó
a la subida de los precios esto ayer en
los mercados mi querido Juan Pablo ya
cerraron las bolsas asiáticas que siguen
los indicadores sigue estar pendiente de
las declaraciones del presidente de la
fe German Powell que en donde Pues él
Espera que se acerque a la redacción del
mercado que diga que pasó con todo el
informe de empleo esto el pasado viernes
se espera también con sus declaraciones
pueda tranquilizar un poco a los
inversionistas que han estado un poco
alterados ahora vamos a Asia porque las
bolsas en ese lugar cerraron en mixto
con los compradores esperando a que
hable el presidente de la fe de Estados
Unidos y en busca de alguna de las
pistas de las decisiones de este banco
en cuanto a las bolsas europeas cerraron
o están operando más bien en terreno
mixto mientras las protestas se dan en
Francia y sea todo un panorama económico
inestable a nivel bursátil y para su
cierre le pido nos recuerde su cifra de
hoy Vámonos con Nintendo porque prometió
Un aumento salarial del 10% a sus
trabajadores esto Pese a que la compañía
tuvo que recortar su pronóstico de
ganancias para todo este año esta buena
noticia para los empleados de Nintendo
se dan en medio del llamado del Primer
Ministro japonés a que las empresas
paguen más a los trabajadores mientras
la inflación se afianza en una economía
acostumbrada a años de deflación
con esto es libre por el día de hoy se
puede ir a descansar y nos vemos mañana
y mañana con mucho más de economía
Gracias Juan Pablo mucho